foreign
hi I'm delighted to be here with my old
friend and collaborator Professor Chris
Manning Chris has a very long and
impressive bio but just briefly he is
Professor of computer science at staff
University and also the director of the
Stanford AI lab and he also has a
distinction of being the most highly
cited researcher in NLP or natural
language processing so really good to be
here with You Chris oh good to get a
chance to chat Andrew
so you know we've known each other
collaborated for many years and one
interesting part of your background I
always thought was that even though
today your distinguished researcher and
machine learning and NLP you actually
started off in a very different area you
your PhD or if ever correctly was in
linguistics and you're studying the
syntax of language so how did you go
from studying syntax to being an NLP
researcher oh so I can certainly tell
you about that but I should also point
out that you know I'm still actually a
professor of linguistics as well I have
a joint appointment at Stanford
um and you know once in a blue moon not
very often I do actually still teach
some real Linguistics as well as some
computer involved natural language
processing
um so
you know so starting out I was very
interested in human languages and how
they work how people understand them how
they're inquired are required so I had
this sort of
um
appeal I saw this appeal in human
languages
um but that equally led me to think
about ideas that we now very much think
about as machine learning or
computational ideas so two of the
central ideas in human language how do
little children acquire human language
and for adults well we're just talking
to each other now and we pretty much
understand each other and you know
that's actually an amazing thing how we
managed to do that so what kind of
processing allows that and so that early
on got me interested in looking at
machine learning in fact even before I'd
made it to grad school I'd started you
know baby steps and learning machine
learning coming off of those interests
yeah in fact all human languages learned
you know we had learned at some point in
the lives to speak English you'd be
grown up in a different place we would
have learned a totally different
language so it's amazing to think how
humans do that and now maybe machines
learn language too but so so so just you
know tell us more about your Journey so
you had a PhD in linguistics and then
and then how did you enter yeah so
there's some stuff before that as well
so I mean you know when I was an
undergrad
um well officially I actually did three
Majors this was in Australia one in math
one in um computer science and one in
linguistics now um people get a slightly
exaggerated sense of what that means if
you're in an American context because
you know it'd be I think impossible to
complete three majors of the undergrad
at Stanford but you know actually where
I was as an undergrad
um doing I did an arts degree so I could
do whatever I wanted like Linguistics
you had to complete two majors to
complete the Arts degree so you know it
was sort of more like double majoring
maybe in U.S terms you probably don't
know this about me but that Carnegie
Mellon I think she was a triple Major
that's CS was once in statistics and
economics
yeah so anyway I did have background and
interest in doing things with computer
science
and so my interests were kind of mixed
and I actually you know when I applied
to grad schools I mean one of the places
I applied to was kind of email and
because they were strong in
computational linguistics you know and
if I'd gone there I would have been
enrolled as a CS student but I ended up
at Stanford as a linguistic student
because at that time there wasn't any
natural language processing in the Cs
department but you know I was still
interested in pursuing ideas natural
language processing but at that point
um in the early 90s things were just
starting to change but the bulk of
natural language processing was
um
rule-based logical declarative systems
but it was also in those years of the
beginning of the 90s when they first
started to be lots of human language
material text and speech available
digitally so this was really actually
just before the World Wide Web exploded
but they'd already started to be things
like legal materials and newspaper
articles and parliamentary hand saws
where you could at last get your hands
on millions of words of human language
and it just seemed really clear that
there had to be exciting things that you
could do by working empirically from
lots of human language and that's what
really sort of got me in involved in a
new kind of natural language processing
that then led into my subsequent career
it sounds like your career was initially
more Linguistics and if the rise of data
and machine learning and empirical
methods it shifted to what NLP and
machine learning and NLP um yeah I mean
it absolutely certainly shifted and I've
certainly sort of shifted much more to
doing
um both natural language processing and
machine learning models but you know to
some extent the balance has varied but
I've sort of been with that as a while
you know actually there's an undergrad
for my undergrad honors thesis
um it was sort of learning the forms of
words so how you came which became a
famous problem of sort of learning past
tense of English verbs and the early
connectionist literature and I was
trying to sort of learn paradigms of
forms of verbs and I was learning rules
for the different forms using the C 4.5
decision Tree Learning algorithm if you
remember that
um
right good times yeah and it's
surprisingly non-intuitive right how
going from present tense to past tense
um from I don't know run to ran and all
the other weird special cases can be
yeah yeah
okay so we talked a bunch about NLP
natural language processing so for some
of the you know um Learners pick up
machine learning for the first time can
you say what is NLP sure absolutely yes
and NLP stands for natural language
processing in other words or term that's
sometimes used for that is computational
linguistics it's the same thing I mean
natural language processing is actually
a weird term right so it's a means that
we're doing things with human languages
so you have to have the conception that
you're enough of a computer scientist
that when you say language you think in
your brain programming language and
therefore you need to say natural
language to mean that you're talking
about the languages that human beings
use so overall natural language
processing is doing anything intelligent
with human languages so in one sense
that breaks down into understanding
human languages producing human
languages acquiring human languages
though people also often think about
about it in terms of different
applications and so then you might think
about things like machine translation or
doing question answering or generating
advertising copy
or
summarization there are so many
different tasks that people work on with
particular goals in mind where you do
things with human language and there's a
lot of natural language processing
because you know so much of what the
world works on our human world is dealt
with and transmitted in terms of human
language material
so um you know because of all of these
applications or even web search right
most of us use NLP right many many times
yeah you're right in some sense the
biggest application of natural language
is web search right and that's really
the the big one I mean traditionally it
was a kind of a simple one right that in
the good old days it was you know there
were various waiting factors and so on
but it was mainly sort of matching
keywords than your Search terms and then
some factors about the quality of the
page it didn't really feel like language
understanding but that's really been
changing over the years so these days
you'll often if you ask a question to a
search engine it'll give you uh you know
an answer box where it has a extracted a
piece of text and puts what it thinks is
the answer in bold or color or something
like that which is then this task of
question answering and then it's really
a natural language understanding task
yeah yeah and and I feel like in in
addition to web searches maybe the big
one you know even when we're going to a
online shopping website or a movie
website and typing in what we want and
doing a website search on a much smaller
website than you know the big search
engines that that also increasingly uses
sophisticated NLP algorithms and it's
also creating quite a lot of value maybe
to you is not you know the real NLP but
it still seems very valuable I agree
it's very valuable and there are there
are lots of interesting problems in any
e-commerce website with search very
difficult problems actually when people
describe the kind of goods they want and
you need to be trying to match it to
products that are available that isn't
an easy problem at all it turns out yeah
sure yeah
so over the last um I don't know a
couple of decades NLP has gone through a
major shift for more of the rule-based
techniques that you alluded to just now
to using really machine learning much
more pervasively
um and so you were one of the people
that you know leading parts of that
charge and seeing every step of the way
you're creating some of the steps has
happened can you can you say a bit about
that process and what you saw sure
absolutely yeah so when I started off as
an undergrad and grad student really
most of natural language processing was
done by hand built
systems which variously used rules and
inference procedures to sort of try and
build up paths and an understanding of a
piece of text what's an example of a
rule or inference system
um so you know a rule could be part of
the structure of human language like
English sentence normally consists of a
subject noun phrase followed by verb and
an object noun phrase and that gives you
some ideas to how to understand the
meaning of the sentence but it might
also be saying something about how to
interpret a word so that a lot of words
in English are very ambiguous but if you
have something like the word star and
it's in the context of a movie then it's
probably referring to a human being on
this astronomical object and in those
days people tried to deal with things
like that using rules of that sort that
doesn't seem very likely to work on
these to us these days but you know once
upon a time that was pretty standard and
so it was only when lots of digital
little text and speech started to become
available that it really seemed like
there was this different way that
instead we could start calculating
statistics over human language material
and building machine learning models and
so that was the first thing that I got
into
um
in the sort of mid to late 1990s and so
the you know the first area where I
started doing lots of research and
Publishing papers and getting well known
is building one in the early days we
often called statistical natural
language processing but it later merged
into in general probabilistic approaches
to artificial intelligence and machine
learning and that sort of took us
through to approximately 2010 let's say
and that's roughly when the new interest
in deep learning using large artificial
neural networks started to take off for
my interest in that I really have you to
thank Andrew because at this stage
um Andrew is still full-time at Stanford
and he was in the office next door to me
and he was really excited about the new
things that were happening in the area
of deep learning I guess anyone who
walked into his office us it tells them
oh it's so exciting what's happening now
and I'm your network you've got to start
looking at that
um and so you know that was really the
impetus that um got me
um pretty early on
um involved in looking at things in
neural networks I had actually seen a
bit of it before so while I was a grad
student here actually Dave rumelhart was
at Stanford and psych and I'd taken his
neural networks class and so you know
I'd seen some of that but it hadn't
actually really been what I'd gotten
into for my own research so
um around I didn't know that thank you
yeah yeah but then and then and then we
wound up you know supervising some
students together yeah absolutely but
I'd love to hear the the rise of also
deep learning in NLP what did you see is
there anything yeah so that so starting
about 2010
um yeah me students started to do the
first
um papers in deep learning and NLP
conferences you know it's always hard
when you're trying to do something new
we had exactly the same experiences that
people 15 or so years earlier it had
when they started trying to do
statistical NLP of when there's an
established way of doing things it's
really hard to push out new ideas so
really some of our first papers were
rejected from conferences and instead
appeared at machine learning conferences
or deep learning workshops but very
quickly that started to change and
people got super interested in neural
network ideas but I I sort of feel like
the neural network period which sort of
started effectively about 2010 itself
divides in two because for the first
period let's say basically say it's till
we showed a lot of success at building
neural networks for all sorts of tasks
we built them for syntactic parsing and
sentiment analysis us and
um
what else did question answering but it
was sort of like we were doing the same
thing that we used to do with other
kinds of machine learning models except
we now had a better machine learning
model and we were sort of instead of
training up a logistic regression or a
support Vector machine we were still
doing the same kind of sentiment
analysis tasks but now we're doing it
with a neural network so I I think in
Looking Back Now in some sense the
bigger change came around 2018 because
that was when the idea of well we could
just start with a large amount of human
language material and build large what a
self-supervised models so that was
models then like Bert and GPT and
successor models for that and they could
just sort of acquire from word
prediction over a huge amount of text
this amazing knowledge of human
languages and I think really probably
the that's going to be viewed in
retrospect as the bigger kind of cut
point where the way things were done
really changed yeah that's it I think
there is that trend for the large
language models learning from massive
amounts of data I think even the lead up
to that there was one of your research
papers that really you know slightly
blew my mind which is a glove paper so
because
um with uh word embeddings where you
learn the vector of numbers you know to
represent a word using a neural network
that was quite that was quite
mind-blowing for me and then the glove
work that you did
um really cleaned up the math made it so
much simpler and then I remember reading
I said oh that's all there is to it and
then you can learn these really
surprisingly detailed representations
with the computer learns real real
nuances of what words mean absolutely
um yeah so I should give a little bit of
credit to others other people also
worked on some similar ideas including
run on caliber air and Jace Western and
Thomas jamika love and colleagues at
Google but
um the glove word vectors is one of the
very prominent and systems of word
vectors so these word vectors already
did yeah you're right illustrate this
idea of using self-supervised learning
that we just took massive amounts of
text and then we could build these
models the new an enormous amount about
the meaning of words I mean it's still
something I sort of show people every
year in the first first lecture of my
NLP class because you know it's
something simple but it actually just
you know works so surprisingly well you
can do this sort of simple modeling of
trying to predict the word given the
words and the context and simply by sort
of running the math of learning to do
those predictions well you learn all
these things about word meaning and you
can do these really nice patterns of you
know similar word meaning or analogies
of something like you know pencil is the
drawing as paintbrush is too and it'll
say painting right that it's sort of
um already showing just a lot of
successful learning um so that that was
the precursor
um to what then got developed to the
next stage with things like Burton GPT
where it wasn't just meanings of
individual words but meanings of whole
pieces of text and context
yeah so I found it amazing that you can
you know take a small neural network or
some model and then give it lots of
English sentences or some other language
and hide the word answer to predict what
is the word that I just hit and that
allows it to learn these analogies these
analogies and these very deep what you
think are really deep things behind the
meaning of the words and then and then
you know 2018 maybe this other
inflection point what what what happened
after that yeah so I mean in 2018
um that was the point in which well sort
of really two things happened one thing
is that people well really in 2017 have
developed this new neural architecture
which was much more scalable onto modern
parallel gpus and so that was the the
Transformer architecture
um the second part of it though was you
know maybe people rediscovered because I
was using the same trick as the glass
model that if you have the task of say
of just predicting a word given a
context either context on both sides of
it or the preceding words that that just
turns out to be an amazing learning task
and that surprises a lot of people and a
lot of the time you see discussions of
where people say disparaging things of
you know this is nothing interesting is
happening all it's doing is statistics
to predict which word is most likely to
come after the preceding words and I
think the really interesting thing is
that that's true but it's not true I
mean because yes what the task is is
you're predicting the the next word
given preceding words but the really
interesting thing is if you want to do
that task really as well as possible
then it actually helps to understand the
whole of the rest of the sentence and
know who's doing what to who in what's
in the sentence but more than that it
also helps to understand the world
because if you're
um your text is going something along
the lines of you know
um
the currency used in Fiji is that well
you need to have some World Knowledge to
know what the right answer to that is
and so good models at doing this learn
both
um to
follow the structure of sentences and
their meaning and to know facts about
the world also that they can predict and
therefore this turns into what sometimes
referred to as an AI complete task right
that you really need there's nothing
that can't actually be useful in
answering
um these what word comes next sense
right you know you can be in the World
Cup semi-finals for teams are and you
need to know something about soccer
um to be giving the right answer yeah
please this funny concept is this idea
that it can solve this one problem you
can solve you know everything in AI
right kind of make an analogy to uh NP
complete problems from the theory of
computing
um what do you think do you think
predicting the next word is AI complete
I have very mixed feelings about that
myself
actually I actually can't say I don't
think it's true I'm curious what you say
uh I think it's not quite true because I
think there are other kinds of things
that human beings manage to work out you
know they're human beings that have
um clever insights in mathematics or
there are human beings who are looking
at something that's a much more you know
three-dimensional real world puzzle of
sort of figuring out how to do something
mechanical or something like that and
that's just not a language problem
but
on the other hand I mean I think
language gets closer to universality
than some people think as well because
you know
we live in this 3D World and
operate in it with our bodies and our
feelings and other creatures and
artifacts around it and you could think
well not much of that is in language at
all but actually just about all of this
stuff we think about we talk about we
write about it in language we can
describe the positions of things
relative to each other in language so a
surprising amount of other parts of the
world are seen in reflection and
language and therefore you're learning
about all of them too when you learn
about language use
you learn about you know one aspect of a
lot of things even if things like how do
you ride a bicycle can't really yeah
yeah so you don't you don't really learn
how to ride a bicycle but you learn some
aspects of what it involves that you
need to balance and you have to have
your feet on the pedals and push them
and all of that kind of things yeah
and so with this trend in NLP the large
language models has been very exciting
for the last several years
where what are your thoughts on where
all this will go
well I mean yeah so it's just been
amazingly
successful and exciting right that so we
haven't really explained all the details
right so there's a first stage of
learning these large language models
um where the task is just to predict the
next word and you do that billions of
times over a very large piece of text
and behold you get this large neural
network which is just a really useful
artifact for all sorts of natural
language processing tasks but then you
still actually have to do something with
it if you want to do a particular task
whether that's question answering or
summarization or detecting toxic content
in social media or something like that
and at that point there's a choice of
things that you could do with it the
traditional answer was then you had a
particular task let's say it's detecting
toxic comments and social media and
you'd take some supervised data for that
and then you'd fine-tune the language
model to answer that classification task
but you were enormously help by having
this base of this large self-supervised
model because it meant that the model
had enormous knowledge of language and
it could generalize very quickly so
unlike the sort of the standard old days
of of supervised learning where it was
kind of well if you give me 10 000
labeled example examples I might be able
to produce a halfway decent model for
you but if you give me 50 000 labeled
examples it'll be a lot better it's sort
of turned it into this world of well if
you give me a hundred labeled examples
then I'm fine-tuning a large language
model I'll be able to do great better
than I would have been able to do with
the 50 000 examples in the old world
some of the more recent exciting works
now even going beyond that it's now well
maybe you don't actually have to
fine-tune the model at all so people
have done a lot of work using methods
sometimes referred to as prompting or
instruction where you can simply in in
natural language perhaps with examples
perhaps with explicit instructions just
tell the model what you want it to do
and it does it
um which you know even as someone who's
been working in natural language
processing for 30 years I mean it
actually just blows my mind how well
this works and you know I guess I wasn't
a decade ago thinking that in
in now we'd be able to just you know
tell
um the model I want you to summarize
this piece of text here and it will then
summarize it
um I think that's incredible
um yeah so
um we're in this very exciting time
where a lot of new
um natural language capabilities are
unfolding I I think there's just no
doubt at all for the next couple of
years the future of that is extremely
bright as people
um work out different things and
different ways to do things and people
start to apply in different application
areas and the kind of capabilities that
have been unlocked with recent
technological developments
you know there's always a question in
technology as to sort of whether the
curve keeps on heading steeply upwards
or whether there's then some new things
we have to discover how to do
it's been
it's been going up for quite a while so
hopefully you know extrapolation is
always dangerous but but we'll see
I'm just curious you know you mentioned
um writing prompts just tell the NLP
system the large language model what you
want in it seems to magically do it I'm
curious do you think prompt engineering
is um the path of the future where it's
actually when I write these prompts I
sometimes find it works miraculously and
sometimes it's frustrating you know the
process of rewording my instructions to
tweak the wording to get it just right
to get into the result I want so do you
think problem engineering is the way of
the future or do you think it's a
intermediate hack until someone invents
a better way to control these control
the outputs of these systems
I think it's both I think
I think it will be the way of the future
but I also think at the moment
um people are doing yeah a lot of
hacking around and rewording
um to
um try and get things to work better and
with any luck with a few more years of
development that'll start to go away I
mean one way of to to think about the
difference is sort of in comparison to
the kind of voice assistance or virtual
assistants that are available on phones
and you know speaker devices like Amazon
Alexa these days right I mean I think
all of us have had the experience that
present those devices aren't always
great but if you know the right way to
word things it'll do something but if
you use the wrong wording it won't you
know and the difference with human
beings is by and large you don't have to
think about that you can say what you
wanted doesn't matter what words you
choose they'll see the other human being
you know assuming that someone who knows
the same language Etc will understand
you and do what you want and I I think
and would hope that we'll start to see
um the same kind of progression with
these models that at the moment you know
fiddling around with the particular
wording you use can make a very big
difference to how well it works but
hopefully in a few years time that just
won't be true you'll be able to use
different wordings and it'll still work
but the basic idea that we're moving
into this age where actually human
language will be able to be used as an
instruction language to tell your
computer what to do so instead of having
to use menus and you know radio buttons
and things like that or writing python
code instead of either of those things
that you'll be able to say what you want
in the computer or do it I I think that
age is opening up in front of us that
will continue to build and that will be
hugely transformative
he's like come a long ways but only a
much more to come and much more to go
yeah absolutely in the development of
NLP technology there's one thing I want
to ask you and I suspect you and I may
have different perspectives on this but
um in the last couple decades the trend
has been to rely Less on rule-based
engineering and more on machine learning
on data sometimes lots of data
um look into the future where do you
think that makes a
hand-coded constraints or other
constraints explicit constraints versus
you know let's get a neural network and
throw lots of data at it where do you
think that balance will fall
um I think that there's no doubt that
using learning from data is the way
forward and what we're going to continue
to do but I think there's still a space
for models that have more structure more
inductive bias that have some kind of
basis of exploiting the nature of
language so in recent years the model
that's been enormously successful is the
Transformer neural network and the
transforming neural networks essentially
this huge Association machine so it'll
just suck associations from anywhere and
look at two words I figure out which
word release to which other word for all
words yes so you use everything to
predict anything and do it over and over
again and you'll get anything you want
and you know that's been incredibly
incredibly successful but it's been
incredibly successful in the domain
where you have humongous humongous
amounts of data right so that these
Transformer models for these large
language models are now being trained on
tens of billions of words of text you
know when I started off in statistical
natural language processing and some of
the traditional linguists used to
complain about the fact that I was you
know collecting statistics from 30
million words of newswire and building a
predictive model and thought you know
that was just not what Linguistics was
about
you know I felt I had a perfectly good
answer which is that you know a human
cared as their learning language they're
exposed to actually well more than 30
million words of data but you know that
kind of amount of data so you know the
kind of amount of data we were using
were perfectly reasonable amounts of
data to be using to be you know not
exactly trying to model human language
acquisition but to be thinking about how
we can learn about language from lots of
data but you know these modern
Transformers are now you know using
already at least two orders of magnitude
more data and you know most most people
think the the way to get things to the
next level is to use more still and make
a three orders magnitude and it you know
in one sense that scaling up strategy
has been hugely effective so you know I
don't blame anybody for saying let's
make another Autumn magnitude bigger and
see what amazing things we can do but it
also shows that human learning is just
way way better in being able to extract
a lot more information out of a quite
limited amount of data and at that point
you can have various hypotheses but I
think it's reasonable to assume that
human learning is somewhat
structured towards the structure of the
world and things that sees in the world
and that allows it to learn more quickly
from less data yeah I'll move you on
that I think better learning algorithms
our current machine learning algorithms
are much less efficient or makes much
less efficient use of data and so
there's way more data than any you know
child um
and then I think whether the improved
learning algorithms will be from
linguistic Like rules or whether it just
be Engineers engineering much more
efficient versions of the Transformer of
whatever comes after it that that is
that will be traditional
I don't I don't think it'll be by people
explicitly putting traditional
linguistic roles into the system I don't
think that's the way forward on the
other hand I mean
you know I think what we're starting to
see is models like these Transformer
models are actually discovering the
structure of language themselves right
so you know the broad facts of
you know human language that you know
English has the subject before the verb
and the object afterwards whereas you
know in Japanese that the verbs at the
end of the sentence and the subject and
object are normally in that order before
it but could be in the other order you
know actually Transformer models are
learning these facts you can interrogate
them and see that even though they were
never explicitly told about subjects and
objects that they know these Notions so
I think they you know they're
discovering a lot else as well about
language use and context and the
meanings and senses of words and what
isn't isn't you know unpleasant language
but it's part of what they're learning
is the same kind of structure that
linguists have laid out as the sort of
structure of different human languages
so as if over many decades linguists
discover certain things and by training
on billions of words Transformers are
discovering the same things that
linguists Discovery yeah absolutely
that's cool
so all this is really exciting progress
in NLP driven by Machine learning and by
other things
um
to someone entering the field entering
machine learning or AI or NLP there's
just a lot going on what advice would
you have for someone wanting to break
into machine learning
yeah well it's a great time to break in
I I think there's just no doubt at all
that we're still in the early stages of
seeing the impact of this new approach
where effectively
software computer science is being
reinvented in on the basis of much more
use of machine learning and the various
other things that come away from that
and then more generally across
Industries there are just lots of
opportunities for more automation making
more use of you know interpretation of
human language material for me or in
other areas like vision and Robotics
this or the same kinds of things so you
know lots of possibilities
um like so you know at that point
there's lots to do obviously in that's
you want to get some kind of good
foundation right so
um knowing some of the core technical
methods of machine learning
understanding ideas of how to build
models from data look at losses do
training diagnose errors all of these
core things I mean that's definitely
useful
um for natural language processing in
particular some of those skills are
completely relevant but then there are
particular kinds of models that are
commonly used including the Transformer
that we've talked about a lot today you
definitely should know about
Transformers and indeed they're
increasingly being used in every other
part of machine learning as well for
vision bioinformatics even robotics is
now using Transformers but beyond that I
think it's also useful to learn
something about human language and the
nature of the problems that involves
because I mean even though people aren't
directly going to be encoding rules of
human language into their Computing
system a sensitivity is a sort of what
kind of things happen in language and
what to look out for and what you might
want to model that's still a useful
skill to have
and then in terms of learning the
foundations learning about these
Concepts um you had entered AI from a
linguistic background and we now see
people from you know all walks of life
wanting to to start doing work and AI
um what are your thoughts on the
preparation one should have or any any
thoughts on how to start from something
other than computer science or AI sure
so there are lots of places you can come
from and Vector across in different ways
and we're seeing tons of people doing
that that they're people who started off
in different areas whether you know it
was chemistry physics
or even much further in field in people
with you know history whatever have
started to look at machine learning I
mean I think there are sort of two
levels of answer there I mean one level
of answer is you know one of the amazing
Transformations is that there's now
these very good software packages for
doing things um with neural network
models I mean this these software is
really easy to use you don't actually
need to understand a lot of Highly
technical stuff you've got need to have
some kind of high level conception about
what is the idea of machine learning and
how do I go about trading a model and
what should I look at in the numbers
that are being printed out to see if
it's working right but you know you
don't actually have to have a higher
degree to be able to build these models
I mean and indeed what we're seeing is
you know lots of high school students
are getting into doing this because it's
actually something that if you have some
basic computer skills and a bit of
programming you can pick up and do it's
just way more accessible than lots of
stuff that preceded it whether in AI or
outside of AI and other areas you know
like operating systems or security but
you know if you want to get to a deeper
level than that and actually want to
understand more of what's going on I
think think you can't really get there
if you don't have a certain mathematics
Foundation like at the end of the day
that deep learning is based on calculus
and you need to be optimizing functions
and if if you sort of don't have any
background in that I think that sort of
ends up as a wall at some point so
um you know the math for machines aren't
even data science it does come in handy
for some of the work yeah
um so if so I think at some level if
you're at the major in history or you
know non-mathematical parts of
psychology I actually have a good friend
who yeah he
um you know learned calculus in grad
school because he was a psychologist and
he'd never done it before and decided
they wanted to start learning about
these new kinds of models and decided it
wasn't too like too late to be able to
go and take account course and so he did
right
um so you know you do need to know some
of that stuff but for lots of people if
they've seen some of that before even if
you're kind of rusty I think you can
kind of get back in the zone and it
doesn't really matter that you haven't
you know done AI as an undergrad or
machine learnings and things like that
that you can really start to learn how
to build these models and do things and
you know really that's my own story
right that despite the fact that they
let me sit in the School of Engineering
at Stanford these days you know my
background isn't as an engineer you know
my PhD is in linguistics that you know
I've sort of largely vectored across
from having some knowledge of
mathematics and Linguistics and knowing
some programming into sort of getting
much more into building AI models
do you think the improved libraries and
abstractions that are now available like
coding Frameworks like tensorflow or
pytorch do you think that reduces the
need to understand calculus because um
boy it's been it's been a while since I
had to actually take a derivative in
order to even implement or create a new
neural network architecture because of
automatic differentiation yeah so yeah I
mean absolutely I mean so in the early
days
um when we were doing things sort of
2010 to 2015 right for every model we
built we were working out the
derivatives by hand and then you know
writing some code and whatever it was
you know sometimes it was python but
sometimes it might have been Java or C
um to calculate these derivatives and
checking that we got them right and so
on where you know
these days you actually don't need to
know any of that to build deep learning
models I mean this is actually something
I think about been thinking about even
with respect to my own natural language
processing with deep learning class that
I teach you know at the beginning we do
still go through doing you know Matrix
calculus and making sure people know
about jacobians and things like that so
that they understand
um what's being done in back propagation
deep learning but you know there's sort
of this sense in which that means that
we just give them hell for two weeks you
know it's sort of like Boot Camp or
something to make them suffer and then
we say oh but you do the rest of the
class with pie torch and they sort of
never have to know any of that again
right I I you know there's always a
question of how deep you want to go in
technical foundations your Aid you can
keep on going right like does a computer
scientist in the 2020s need to
understand you know electronics and
transistors or what happens
um in you know CPU well you know it's
complicated I mean in various ways it is
helpful to know some of that stuff I
mean you know I know Andrew you were one
of the pioneers and getting machine
learning onto gpus and well you know
that sort of means you had to have some
sense that there's this new hardware out
there and it has some attributes of
parallelism that means there's likely to
be able to do something exciting so you
know it is useful to have some broader
knowledge and understanding and you know
sometimes something breaks and if you
have some deeper knowledge you can
understand why it broke but there's
another sense in which you know most
people have to take some things on trust
and you can do most of what you want to
do in neural network modeling these days
without knowing calculus at all
yeah I think that's a great point I feel
like sometimes the reliability of the
abstraction determines how often you
need to go in to fix something that's
broken so I I'm actually my
understanding of quantum physics is very
weak I barely understand it so you can
argue I don't understand how computers
work because transistors are filth and
quantum physics but fortunately you know
if something went wrong with a
transistor I've never had to go
they're a bit hard to fix I think
and and so I think I think um or another
example you know the sort function the
libraries to sort things and sometimes
they actually don't work right swapping
a memory or whatever and that's when if
you really understand how the sort
function works you can go in and fix it
but then sometimes if we have
abstractions libraries apis are reliable
enough then that is nice to those
abstractions then diminishes the need
yeah to understand some of the things
that happen underneath so this is an
exciting World feels like yeah we have
Giants building on the shoulders of
giants and all of these things becoming
more context and more exciting every
every month really yeah absolutely so
thanks Chris that was really um
interesting and inspiring and I hope
that to everyone watching this hearing
Chris's own Journey
um to become a computer scientist and
become a leading maybe leading NLP
computer scientists as well as all of
this exciting work having an NFP right
now I hope that inspires you too to jump
into this field and take a go at it
there's just a lot more work to be done
collectively by our community that still
so I think the more of us are working on
this the better of the world will be so
thanks a lot Chris it was really great
having you here thanks a lot Andrew it's
been fun chatting